hold your daughter's 14 and 12 they both
have their periods if that's what you're
asking
oh we can't talk about this no no can I
just make it really clear that's not
what I was asked what did ask that it's
aggressive
what yeah yeah the pull period thing
yeah oh no I did not see that coming no
way no one no one told you about that
boy I knew it's gonna happen I just
didn't think I'd be around my oldest got
hers first that's how it happens right
and so she gets hers thank God I wasn't
there I was on the road I would have
ruined that yeah I'm like all right you
go to the river and do laundry for a
week your dirty
god she melted down so you told my wife
I'm not ready to be a big girl I want it
I don't want to be a big girl and my
wife's like honey this is life they got
doughnuts watch Downton Abbey done right
she handled it perfect Oh I came home I
was like she's like Georgia got her
period and I was like what do you need
me to do she's like we got it
I let my youngest got hers on a Friday
now Fridays my wife goes to therapy and
her chiropractor so I they got her to
school called the house I answered she's
like dad I got my period I was like
prank call or prank caller
I was like you called the wrong number
call your mom but then I
started thinking she's panicking she
needs a parent on my card I can handle
this I go okay how'd you get it like you
know like visit traumatic yes you like
were you accepting an award in front of
the whole school or like my wife got
hers at a football game wearing white
pants oh my god no it was an Alabama
football game so her dad was like she
believed school colors roll time on the
align Amaro I can handle this okay okay
baby what do you need for me new pants
new panties new socks didn't get your
socks like a bucket a bucket a towel
some garlic we had to keep the vampires
away and then she's like dad I'm fine
mom gave me a go bag and I go over them
what are you calling me for she was like
I need you to go to the store and get
supplies I'm throwing a period party
tonight you never you never heard it
I've never heard of this is real this is
real she goes dad I'm throwing a period
party I'm gonna kill Mike what's that
she goes I need you to the store and get
a red velvet cake I'm like dude all the
girls are throwing them dad red velvet
cake and icing so we can name my period
what name they know I got that I said I
go who names their period she's like
Georgia named hers after the girl from
progressive auto insurance I swear to
God actually makes sense yeah and then
she's like she's like dad please I got
ten people coming tonight
I go ten people she's yeah eight girls
and two boys I go who advised boys to a
beautiful she's like that's the fun of
it dad we don't tell him either there
[Applause]
so what did you get I got beet juice
pomegranate juice pasta with marinara
sauce catsup of fries red velvet cake
and my white red wine my wife Carl's
like what are you doing I'm going
oh I'll I got her period I'm getting a
red velvet cake my wife's like I'd go
yeah we're having a period party and it
was awesome the period I hope to god you
hear it in a positive manner and you
fathers get to throw your daughter a
period party because it was awesome
these two boys the whole time have red
cake all over their face like their cage
fighters and they're like who's Jason
she named it Jason because he got her
period on Friday the 13th
I got a picture I put on my Instagram
stories I got a picture of the cake
let's see it there we go yeah I say P P
thank you God
you